so I want to welcome you all today thank
you again for coming out and thank you
also those who have made this possible
I'm thinking of course of Roger hertog
as generosity managed is what made all
this possible not just this lecture
series but our research program a lot of
other things as well thank you to the
Arnold Saltzman Institute for
co-sponsoring this lecture series and
the School of International and public
affairs thank you all and thank you
especially tonight to Bob gallucci for
coming out and speaking with us I think
all of you already know that Bob is the
president of the MacArthur Foundation he
also was for many years the Dean of the
Edmund wall School of Foreign Service at
Georgetown but also tonight when you
think of our subject I think he is
uniquely qualified to speak to the
history and future of nuclear
proliferation because after all for 21
years he served in a series of
government positions where he was at the
very centre of things in the evolving
problem of nuclear proliferation both
vertical proliferation the way the US
and the Soviets for building their
Arsenal's to the 1970s when for a time
use the arms control and disarmament
agency and also in terms of horizontal
proliferation whether it's the the
threat of loose nukes in the former
Soviet Union where for a time he worked
with the those who are working to
implement the nunn-lugar legislation but
also in in Iraq where for a time he is
working in the United Nations special
commission on disarmament and then of
course I think what we all know and for
which is as the lead negotiator with
North Korea in the 1990s and during the
the Clinton administration so in all
these ways bob has really been at the
center of things and so he's really
uniquely qualified to speak to the
present threat of nuclear proliferation
so with no further ado let me turn
things over to him and thank him again
for coming tonight thank you Bob
I had a number of different ideas about
how we would spend our time this evening
that is to say how I'd spend my part of
the time and then you could ask what you
want to ask and I thought of focusing on
one case like the North Korean case or
the Pakistan case or the Iran case the
rock case but I thought I'd try
something different which is to offer a
sort of framework for how I think you
might think about the proliferation of
nuclear weapons it isn't particularly
political science e as in discipline
rigorous but it it it seems to me that
there were three ways of approaching
proliferation and I recollect there were
three policy responses over years now
let me just some of this is my own
personal history i went into government
in 1974 and you remember the Indians
detonated their first pick your device
then this is not causal I didn't cause
this nothing to do with it but the
structure of my life in terms of the
people around me in government seemed to
follow these three approaches or because
I was a student of Kenneth Walt's always
liked using the word image you know
taking on delusions of intellectual
grandeur here but still at least three
three different approaches to the
proliferation issue and I want to
describe those to you and and so
intellectually where we word how we have
thought about this over the years and
then place us now in that context and
then we can have a discussion about the
now stuff for the historical stuff if
you are interested okay
the first model the first image the
first approach to the proliferation
issue seems to me the inevitably the
systemic approach it is one that
proceeds from the proposition that
states will inevitably acquire nuclear
weapons because the security dilemma
defines the essence of the self-help
system which is the international system
states will to protect themselves
acquire whatever weapons will help them
do that for their own self-defense
the image that that this captures is one
of a world though therefore over time of
many nuclear weapon states and it does
not seem to meet me an accident that
when people first were rigorously
thinking about the proliferation of
nuclear weapons as a major threat to
American security and allied security as
opposed to just the Soviet threat which
had dominated our thinking from the late
40s through the 50s they began to see a
world and envision a world that was
essentially systemically determined and
for those who are a fan of the third
image vaulted like this right but
beginning with John Kennedy who famously
in the early 60s predicted that by the
70s in a decade or so that there'd be 15
to 25 nuclear weapon states now when he
made this prediction there were three
the United States Britain and the Soviet
Union and then of course in the 60s we
added France and China in the late 60s
the academic who whose field was plif
rationed he dominated it was George
Questor who by the way is still a
professor at the University of Maryland
and still writing on nuclear issues and
in the late 60s when I was a graduate
student he predicted again famously that
by the 90s looking out 20 years they
would be 50 or 50s a 50 or more nuclear
weapon States and as a graduate student
Irene I actually made a bet with
somebody that it wouldn't happen that it
was actually a bet about how many states
they would have Mickey weapons in by the
mid 70s because we could act we could
think that far advanced that was six or
seven years out I don't remember the
details of the bet and I never got paid
but I was right so what I'm saying
is that that was the imagery that was
the thinking it was a view about that
this would happen as a result of the
character of the international system
and the nature of the security dilemma
and it for evidence that we were not
thinking then and I could say we in the
late sixties as a graduate student who I
was interested in this topic then we
weren't thinking so much of the most
recent states that would be as I said
France and China and we certainly
weren't thinking of the Soviet Union
United States and Britain we were
thinking of other states out there and
then in 1974 when India the spring
detonated a nuclear explosive device a
claim that was a peaceful nuclear
explosion if he would recall but that's
what they said this was real evidence
that this image this approach this model
was correct because we were then
politically incorrect and we called
India an underdeveloped country at that
point we don't say that anymore about a
country we call them developing
countries but they was in India was then
an underdeveloped country and if in
India if India could detonate a nuclear
explosive device then we said any state
could write any state could in any state
would India wasn't particularly under
threat it was us you know from you oh
yes they did have a certain China
problem but they didn't have a Pakistan
problem Pakistan and India problem but
but the asymmetry enforces went in
India's favor at the conventional level
so this was driven by something else and
that what this was driven by was we
argued an inevitable force of the
international system the character of
the national system so that's the first
model and it leads to that kind of
expectation about the future the second
model which I think informed thinking
was a lot less that bill if eration
would be driven by systemic
inevitability and much more by
capability
those who believe proliferation was
probably just as unavoidable as those
who took like the first model looked
around and saw this is in the 70s saw
the embrace of nuclear energy if you
look back you will find that the 70s was
an enormous growth period at least in
declaratory policy and actually in a
fair amount of building as well in the
United States and elsewhere nuclear
energy was on the move not only was
nuclear energy on the move but a
particular method of enjoying nuclear
energy put in that in quotes enjoying
your energy had taken hold in the united
states and i will say therefore
internationally and that was the embrace
of the full nuclear fuel cycle and this
is very important and i'm going to now
do this
the idea here is that
uranium for the kind of reactors I'm
talking about the United States is 104
nuclear reactors give or take and right
now we have maybe some weights been a
quarter and a third of all the nuclear
reactors in the world still largely they
are light water reactors and that means
the neutrons are slowed down by regular
water and natural uranium will not
sustain a reaction in that light water
reactor so not only do you need to mine
uranium you then need to enrich uranium
then after you enrich uranium and you
fabricate the fuel and a fuel
fabrication facility the fuel goes into
a nuclear reactor after the fuel gets
burned up the fuel comes out of the
nuclear reactor and it goes in a spent
fuel storage pond which looks to all the
world like a swimming pool not a good
place to swim but a swimming pool and
that's where the fuel is stored for how
long well at least two years well or for
how long 50 years we still have fuel
from our first reactors sitting in
storage ponds that was not the image
this does not look like a cycle to you
does it it doesn't but the foot you must
have heard the phrase fuel cycle that's
what was embraced and this is very
important to my argument here because
the next step according to the nuclear
engineers that not only inform the
United States but we trained I mean
where did the engineers in India come
from who did the India bomb we trained
them at North Carolina State for
goodness sake so the next step we taught
everybody was a reprocessing plant or a
chemical separation plant it's called
both and in that plant three streams
come out radioactive waste uranium and
plutonium
in the dreams of the nuclear engineers
tone IAM and the uranium are mixed
together and they go into a fuel
fabrication facility and mixed oxide
fuel is produced mixed oxide not just
uranium oxide which goes here but
plutonium oxide to the two of mixed
together to form a mixed oxide and some
fuel rods have MOX fuel and some have
regular fuel and they go back into the
reactor to be burned now you see cycle
now why am I taking time to tell you all
this interesting stuff because if one is
interested in nuclear weapons there are
two points in this fuel cycle from which
one can get the material for a nuclear
weapon this is one of them and
enrichment plant as you probably know
the Iranians say that they aren't have
an enrichment plant to enrich uranium
for their one nuclear reactor and their
many more and they see in the future and
we observed that that Richmond plant
could be run to produce not just
low-enriched uranium leu but high in
rich geranium what are they enrich
enriched in its enriched in the isotope
uranium 235 and uranium 235 at
eighty-five ninety percent can be used
to make a nuclear weapon so this is one
of the two materials that can be used to
make a nuclear weapon the weapon we
dropped on Hiroshima was a highly
enriched uranium core weapon the other
material one could use mecha nuclear
weapon is plutonium where does plutonium
come from it comes from separated spent
fuel comes out of spent fuel plutonium
does not occur in nature it's produced
in a nuclear reaction by transmutation
in the reactor it's contained in spent
fuel and it sits there unless you have
one of these guys if you have one of
these guys you can get plutonium out
that's the other material to use for a
nuclear weapon in the bomb we dropped on
Nagasaki was made from plutonium so
if you remember what I was talking about
before talking about capabilities driven
model as long as we thought the world
was going to be filled with nuclear
energy and we thought nuclear energy was
going to be dominated by the full fuel
cycle we thought countries that acquired
nuclear energy would acquire a full fuel
cycle would acquire an enrichment plant
and reprocessing wet as it turned out we
later thought that it's not a good idea
we will sell enrichment services and
make money so let's don't spread around
enrichment facilities but reprocessing
terrific it also helps for waste
management we argued terrific what about
the plutonium well you were going to
recycle it back into the reactor well
what about if somebody's diverts it will
have international atomic energy agency
safeguards to make sure they don't
divert it so we had a theory of how this
would happen but anybody who was in the
business and I was at that point in the
business in the mid-70s by that time I
was in government anybody who would work
these issues knew you couldn't really
safeguard a large reprocessing plant the
amount of material that would go
unaccounted for could be used to make
weapons and this was essentially an
invitation as we argued for this type of
a fuel cycle for catastrophe an
inevitability so we thought in a
somewhat the same way but with a
different kind of argument that nuclear
energy spread would make nuclear weapons
spread inevitable there was of course
also the commercial incentive for the
sale of reactors for the sale of all
this nuclear technology a lot of money
was going to be made by Westinghouse and
General Electric by licensing their
technologies abroad one made a boiling
water reactor another made a pressurized
water reactor one went
french fry metal build the westinghouse
reactor the Germans built the boiling
water reactor general journal electric
so there was a lot of money to be made
in spreading this technology and we
spread this technology light water
reactor technology everywhere technology
therefore was not just a means but
technology was was the driver in a way
that the in the first model the security
glimmer was a driver okay image again
would have a sea would have us have
nuclear weapons in an awful lot of
countries the third image the third
model because did not proceed from
assumption of any systemic inevitability
or technological inevitability it
proceeded from an image of the character
of states and the character of regions
it the proposition was that for internal
reasons states might want nuclear
weapons or for regional security reasons
and therefore the approach and the
responses were different when I was in
government we had in this is nineteen
seventy six ish we're thinking then
about a certain set of countries not all
the countries certain set of countries
which we regarded as threshold there
were 12 we were not politically correct
as I said so we called them the Dirty
Dozen a movie with Lee Marvin I
recommended this this this group of
countries there were two in Northeast
Asia Korea and Taiwan Korea was not
North Korea but South Korea which had an
icky weapons program south south asia
had India and Pakistan the Middle East
had Iran Iraq Israel Egypt and Libya
Africa had South Africa and Latin
America had Brazil and Argentina so we
saw a definite group of countries
through our analysis of both the
regional dynamic and the internal
politics we thought these were the
threshold countries and we focused
if you had this image when focused on
these particular countries so the
nuclear weapons were seen in this third
image as an expression of a national
identity and as necessary to meet
regional needs be because these models
actually are quite different in the
assumptions they make about the nature
of decision-making in states they led to
different policy prescriptions the first
model led to so this is a systemic
approach it is what was behind the idea
of a nuclear non-proliferation treaty I
mean look at this treaty it's a deal
between the non-nuclear weapon States
and the five at that point at that point
the five nuclear weapon states that
would for all con read the treaty
legitimize those five states as nuclear
weapon states in exchange for their
commitment to assist other countries and
getting peaceful nuclear technology and
for their commitment ultimately to give
up their nuclear weapons a systemic
approach this is one of the most
universal treatise on the planet has 189
adherence I think at the moment which is
very nearly all the states in the world
along wizard in 1957 Kenneth treaty was
marriage negotiations were in 68 entry
into force was 73 the long along around
the same period the International Atomic
Energy Agency in Vienna as an entity
that would over time apply safeguards
under the treaty initially it did it
through bilateral agreements called
information circular insert 666 morphed
after 1973 and circa 153 and every state
that wanted to have nuclear energy was
required really to make a negotiation
successful negotiation with the IAEA for
the application of safeguards to any
nuclear equip
they received from another country so
the IAEA inspectors were going all over
the world providing us fundamental and
essential assurance that nuclear
equipment would be used to produce
nuclear material exclusively for
peaceful purposes non-explosive peaceful
purposes so this was the character
systemic I meant to be universal model
to the the capabilities model let us
some lonesome place entirely different
it led us to denial if you thought
technology was the problem you really
weren't going to focus necessarily on
the systemic approach of the IAEA and of
the NPT you were looking to deny
countries access to sensitive technology
and sensitive technology was a phrase
that covered essentially two things the
enrichment plant and the reprocessing
plant if you denied the enrichment plant
they didn't get highly enriched uranium
if you denied your processing plant they
didn't get plutonium if they didn't get
either of those they didn't have fissile
material they couldn't make a weapon so
the huge effort begun really in 1976
with the creation of something called
the London group which was six countries
and then grew into the Nuclear Suppliers
group of over 40 countries that were
dedicated to denying the transfer of
sensitive technology to sense quote to
sensitive regions and it essentially
meant two countries we really really
were suspicious of so could we transfer
this technology to the Dutch yeah that's
okay do we want to transfer it to Taiwan
I don't think so right so that's how
that worked at it it took a while to get
denial to be accepted internationally
but it essentially was and that was at
the heart of the prescription that
followed from model to inta see also
what is into the entity is INF siiii
international nuclear fuel cycle
II thank you annecy was like a domestic
program n sap which was which was
pursued in the United States it was an
effort to develop yeah that's not quite
right it was an effort to assess and
perhaps promote proliferation resistance
technologies proliferation resistance is
alike what's written on the back of your
wristwatch you know I don't write
waterproof they what right water
resistant and he couldn't really have a
comp liberation proof nuclear fuel cycle
but or neo technology which it could
have resistant and the way you would do
that is there are many mechanisms in the
fuel cycle that one can either introduce
that would make diversion theft or
out-and-out assertion of authority over
the fuel cycle seizure ineffective and
the idea was to develop more of these
type of nuclear technologies not
tremendously successful in my view but
it was it was another response that
turned on the technical approach in the
United States The MITRE report that was
done during the Ford administration
influenced strongly to thinking of
President Carter and when President
Carter came into office in 1976-77
actually he froze work on the plutonium
fuel cycle so not only not only did he
say that the United States of America
would not reprocess spent fuel he also
said that our enthusiasm for something
called a fast breeder reactor was going
to be still a fast breeder reactor is a
nifty idea in concept it is
some of you may have heard that it
produces more fuel than it consumes
doesn't that sound absolutely lovely
well what happens is that there is a
core of fissile material and then a
blanket of what's called fertile
material and some of the neutrons here
instead of producing heat and energy are
used to convert the blanket into more
fissile material and so the metaphor
might be if you build a fire if you've
ever gone camping and you take some wet
wood and stack it around your a little
fire after a while you might have more
fuel than you started with isn't that
remarkable but it meant some of the heat
instead of warming you warmed the wood
and this is a metaphor to this well
Carter ended that the French went on
with breeder development the Japanese
went on with Brida development that
Russians went on up redevelopment nobody
has been successful in in the last 30 or
40 years but the idea here what I'm
really arguing to you is that this was
another expression or manifestation of
the second model the prescription that
would come out of it was let's deal with
the technology and make the technology
safer if you were a believer in Monell 3
and that's where my career was largely
you focused on in a way much more
traditional diplomacy particularly
bilateral diplomacy I would run
screaming from the room at the thought
that I would be involved in multilateral
diplomacy and was much more comfortable
dealing with a thug one on 1i that's a
much more pleasing and something I
understand from having grown up on Long
Island and this is a it's just easier
for me to cope with so if you look
around at alliances for example I would
say alliances if you view them not just
in the terms in which they are
negotiated for the security of the state
but view them as a non-proliferation
mechanism they are addressing the
security of states that could build
weapons for their own security so the
countries in NATO have the nuclear
umbrella the Japanese I mean how long
would it take the Japanese to build
nuclear weapons if they decided to I
mean seriously not long right and you
know they would be good I mean there
would be good I mean they would be small
did hum they be good be good be
beautiful make of the weapons right so
we we know this weed but there's the
mutual security treaty security has met
but in the context of that treaty that's
the korea republic of korea same idea
even taiwan even taiwan well it's not a
formal treaty we were able to persuade
the Taiwanese because of our
relationship with the peoples on Taiwan
that nuclear weapons was not a good idea
for them so alliances were part of the
policy response here traditional
diplomacy when we discovered the nuclear
weapons program in in in North and South
Korea we went over and visited soul and
we have conversations we have done that
in other countries where we've
discovered the we're diplomacy sometimes
very quiet diplomacy turns out to be
effective in that case i would say war
this is a point in the talk where I say
let's give war a chance and if we looked
at the Iraqi case okay so I'm very
familiar with a very robust nuclear
weapons program that we uncovered after
the first invasion of Iraq and i would
say that six months a year at most from
the time we invaded Iraq in 1991 that
the Iraqis would have had a workable
nuclear weapon fissile material to make
it work so we blocked that with with
with our invasion we are not talking
about the second invasion which is a
different kind of story I would also say
that you engage in this kind of
diplomacy if you have this model of what
drives blip raishin sometimes not to
solve the problem for all time but to
give other mechanisms a chance so
South Africa South Africa actually you
know was subject to a lot of pressure
from the United States we discovered the
hole in the desert in the Kalahari we
discovered it with the help of the
Russians who said look here and we
looked there and we found them digging
this home he said what's that for and
they said security and we said it looks
like a hole for the used to explode a
nuclear device and they sit down no no
it was we later found out for that but
we knew that it was that and we
persuaded them not to go ahead and of
course with the passage of time the
apartheid regime disappeared and then
ultimately we found out that the South
Africans had indeed built six nuclear
weapons and they were dismantled and the
fissile material is subjected to IAEA
safeguards so you can actually reverse
proliferation you know under this model
that's a good thing to happen under this
model we spent a lot of time in Brasilia
in NBA in Buenos Aires trying to
persuade both countries that nuclear
weapons really were not a good idea for
Latin Americans and over time both of
them gave up nuclear weapons programs
now it doesn't mean you don't solve this
problem for all time ever because people
don't forget how to do this but you this
is an issue that needs constant
management and in this third model it
means constant political military
diplomacy I note parenthetically this is
not of interest unless you are a Graham
Allison acolyte and you and I am one by
the way like to look at the processes of
government but we divided ourselves in
government according to these three
models I mean we didn't have the models
and I made up the models afterwards but
there was a group that did multilateral
diplomacy you know the worried about the
NPT that worried about review conference
is worried about the IAEA and all that
sort of thing they were there there's
another group that were essentially
nuclear engineers nuclear physicists
Department of Energy played the
laboratories played and they were the
technology people and then there were
the political military types like myself
who had to know about the first two but
we're really interested in
with individual countries in individual
negotiations so these were really three
sets of bureaucrats operating
differently for the same objectives okay
some observations how much time we have
by the way I feel like I'm going on a
bit here another you know Lisa 20
minutes say or a half an hour okay I
mean yeah all right some observations we
do not ladies and gentlemen have a world
of 90 nuclear weapon states right now we
have a world of nine nuclear weapon
States the original five plus four with
one state a threshold state original
five the United States and Soviet Union
and Britain and France and China before
Israel India Pakistan North Korea and
then the threshold state now the
threshold state Iran this is after 65
years nine states that's the first
observation the second is that well I
like the idea of breaking this out into
different models the world of course
doesn't work according to models and I
think each has some something to
contribute to a complex explanation of
why things happen the way they do in the
international system so i'm not here to
tell you the one model is preferable to
the other but i find the phenomenon of
proliferation to be complex the
motivations for states to be complex and
policy responses to have to be
comparably complex to be successful
third I am tempted to say policy worked
that may not be right of course but i
like it because this is what I did for
over 20 years so I like that the idea
that maybe what we did did some good but
it is undoubtedly true that
circumstances changed to over these
years and not the least of which was the
chilling of enthusiasm for nuclear
energy not only did we have three mile
island
but there was Chernobyl and we have not
had a reactor start in this country
since the Milan yes I know about Nikki
Renaissance and i want to say worried
about that but i think this is because
of that second image not a trivial part
of the explanation about why we are
where we are at this moment the fourth
observation is that the current
situation is both difficult and
dangerous that leads us to the current
situation to me briefly to situations
characterized the current landscape the
first is the situation in South Asia if
you ask most people that are in the
security business this part of the
security business they will tell you the
place where it is most likely that one
state would use a nuclear weapon against
another state in South Asia we have two
countries with deliverable nuclear
weapons with an arsenal so we have to
Arsenal's these two countries Arsenal's
are not enormous though the Pakistani
one is growing what's the significance
of it being not enormous if your model
is the US and the Soviet Union and
you're thinking wait a minute it's good
to have nuclear weapons there there are
those who make this argument they will
deter each other if you're thinking that
think about the requirements of
deterrence and think about analytically
what characterized in important ways the
us-soviet relationship you will not find
the important features in the
pakistan-india relationship one of the
things you will not find at least yet is
a secure second strike acknowledged by
both sides now will they eventually get
there plausibly but right now you have
arguably the worst of anything you have
the possibility of a disarming first
strike in one of the other or both of my
mind's in in Pakistan and India that's
very bad for stability and deterrence
small forces of very bit small
vulnerable forces are even worse neither
of these countries have
submarine-launched ballistic missiles
yet neither of them have built really
hard in silos yet the delivery systems
or aircraft some missiles missiles have
some mobility and essentially they hide
things that's not exactly foolproof so
that's one second I would like to point
something out about India and Pakistan
that you may not have noticed they are
contiguous the second thing you may not
have noticed the United States and
Soviet Union essentially not
withstanding what sarah palin and said
are not contiguous what I'm saying is
that for all those decades of us Soviet
relations there were periphery we had
any number of conflicts with the Soviets
in which people died but not directly
there were geostrategic peripheries
Africa Asia elsewhere where things could
happen and never engage a vital interest
of the others why do we all love the
Cuban Missile Crisis a because we won
but be because that was so
geographically proximate to us it was
plausible that we might actually have a
nuclear exchange over it what I'm saying
to you is that India and Pakistan it's
very hard for them to go to war and not
engage a vile interest because they're
not going to go to Australia to have the
war they're going to have it on the
territory of one or the other or both
vital interests will immediately be
engaged that's not a good situation if
you're trying to avoid those situations
in which the use of nuclear weapons
become politically plausible third
because they're contiguous there's an
enormous time pressure in a crisis to
make a quick decision it's also
exacerbated substantially by the
vulnerability of one's own systems
particularly your perception of your
ability relative to the other side if
you have to make a decision quickly and
you think you're in a and here's the
phrase use or lose situation that's bad
for stability so all I'm trying to do
here is tell you that this is not a
happy situation in which you should feel
confident deterrence will prevail
there's a ever-present source of
conflict for this country least two
countries that have it have gone to war
any number of times that would be
cashmere of course and that chronic
source of conflict which led to the
dismemberment of one of the two states
is ever present as a possible source of
a war that could escalate to the nuclear
level so South Asia second I would say
there is the case of Iran it is possible
that Iran will preserve the option to
build nuclear weapons but not actually
build make your weapons that is a
possibility I consider it more likely
that one or two other things would
happen that they will in fact build
nuclear weapons or that another state
that which could be us will use force to
prevent them from building nuclear
weapons that will not be an easy
decision it won't be easy for the United
States to watch Iran acquire nuclear
weapons because of the implications for
the Middle East if it does and it
certainly wouldn't be easy for the
United States to use conventional
conventional strike to stop the Iranians
because they would have to be a very
protracted strike and you have to be
planning on restrike because of the
character of our conventional capability
in the character of the hardening of
their facilities so
this is not a happy situation is not a
good ending to this data anybody I know
of really predicts and the possibility
of the use of force the provocation that
these weapons would have an Iranian
hands for Arabs minions of course not
Arabs and for the Middle East is is
potentially catastrophic the third case
of course is North Korea we worry about
North Korea for a variety of reasons not
the least of which that is that over a
period of time the North Korean program
could prove to be a provocation to South
Korea and or Japan leading them to
acquire nuclear weapons for a variety of
reasons not least of which being
domestic political pressure to do so so
these are hard cases they look like
model 3 to me separate solutions not
systemic solutions not particularly
technically driven anymore much more
like model 3 problems open to model 3
solutions if there are any finally my
last point here is that the current
situation in proliferation is for me not
importantly defined by what I have been
in talking about it is not importantly
defined by the state acquisition of
nuclear weapons for me our security in
the United States and that of our allies
as much more likely to be directly
affected by the acquisition of a nuclear
device by a terrorist group in the
introduction of that device into a city
for our purposes in American city for
your purposes this city it is I hope to
get your attention now it is to me
implausible if we don't do something
different implausible
that we will get away with 10 or 20
years without having a nuclear weapon
detonated in New York City I say that
because I do not see a defense by denial
against Mickey weapons acquisition by a
terrorist group in other words I don't
see how we could defend by denial in a
classic sense of denying access to our
shores remember the weapon would podium
is a nice size for first-generation
improvised nuclear device by the way the
two models here one they steal Nicki
weapon be they build one I'm working on
be as more likely than a even though a
is a lot more fun for the movies I like
B is a lot more more concerned to me
that basic device is this and the
question is if you had a weapon that was
as big as this podium and you were
someplace in Africa or the middle east
or southeast asia could you figure out a
way with high confidence of getting it
into the united states could you figure
it out figure out a way or would you be
stymied by the extraordinary security at
all of our borders the way our marinas
are completely controlled by the Coast
Guard so that no ship goes in and out
without being searched the way the
northern border of the United States is
constantly patrolled the way nobody ever
gets in the southern border no defense
by denial defense by deterrence defense
by deterrence against an enemy that
values your death more than his life I
don't think so so the defense is to
prevent this country from acquiring
excuse me this group from acquiring the
fissile material well what's the rub
their the rub there is that there's
Pakistan there's Russia neither country
wants to has a leadership that wants to
transfer fees on
terial to a terrorist group but we know
that Pakistan and many scenarios will
not have a grip on its vishaal material
we know that Russia still is not up to
our standards in securing its vishaal
material remember we're talking about in
the Russian case hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of tons of fissile material
when an amount of material that would
fit in that bottle would give you
Nagasaki and in this city would give you
at Ground burst at noontime ish would
give you on the order of a quarter of a
million people dead some of them
promptly and some within four to six
weeks I'm not talking about long-term
radiation here than that that's we were
stunned as we ought to have been by nine
eleven 3,000 and I'm talking a quarter
of a million people the for me we should
recast the Iranian case the North Korean
case those cases are to me even though I
just spoke to you in terms of
proliferation the domino effect in the
region that's not what they're really
about for me I know I don't live in New
York I live in Chicago my daughter lives
here and I like the people in New York
but it's about the transfer of material
and before you say oh no now you are
talking about some TV show 24 tues gonna
what country I've been acting in debates
but what country is going to transfer
who well did you miss the story about
North Korea building a plutonium
production reactor in Syria did that
wouldn't blow by you or did you notice
do you know what a plutonium production
reactors it's one of those reactors that
is not built for energy it's that's why
they call it a production reactor it's
we built in the United States at
Savannah River a couple of other places
reactors not for energy purposes but for
plutonium production hence lieutenant
Tony production reactor that's what the
North Koreans built in Syria and we
didn't catch him at it and you're gonna
catch a bottle being transferred I don't
think so I don't think so and what would
possess them to do it to make money
they're hungry I'm not know speaking
sympathy for North Korea I'm just making
a point I'm not pleased as day varies to
say I'm not making this up please check
it out the Israelis did destroy that one
side but there that is to me proof
positive and by the way for all the
extraordinary red line drawing of a last
administration we did absolutely nothing
after that happened would you like to be
dependent on serious decision making
over the disposition of the plutonium of
their secret plutonium production
facility would you like to depend on
Iran's Iran right now supplies more
conventional weapons to groups that we
regard as terrorists than any of the
state on the planet and there on the
edge of producing fissile material I
take this all very seriously and now if
this doesn't catch your attention try my
closer we are in the midst of what many
people in this country including the
President of the United States and
honorable man in the Secretary of Energy
another honorable man and everybody
senior in this administration many of
them I have known for a long time not
all of them but some of them in the
midst of embracing a nuclear renaissance
that may well include the use of
plutonium fuels because because they are
describing the terrorist threat as the
principal threaten and the material for
a terrorist threat to be only highly
enriched uranium
bomb design number one
imagine that's a sphere imagine these
are high explosive lenses imagine as
fissile material here this makes what's
called an implosion system these
explosives compress this material till
it is supercritical and you get a
nuclear that was the Nagasaki bomb this
it's another design this is fissile
material and in fact it is heu everybody
in the administration who works on these
issues has been taught something which I
will now teach you there are only there
are two basic designs for a nuclear
weapon this design is the simpler of the
two this is essentially a tube
conventional explosive at one end
detonated and high explosive in excuse
me and physical goes down the tube hits
the other and you get a super critical
mass and you get an explosion this was
the Hiroshima device this produced about
12,000 tons of TNT equivalent Katie this
is his Nagasaki produced around 18 kt
you can only make this device with
highly restrain iam this device called
an implosion system can be made with
either plutonium or highly missed
rhenium yell with me a terrorist it is
said cannot make one of these too hard
terrorists can only make one of these
but one of these can only be made with
hu so we can control hu we've controlled
the terrorist threat and we don't have
to worry about plutonium this is
technical nonsense it is in every book
that I have ever seen about
non-proliferation it also is informing
the thinking of the administration as
best I know it's at least a forming some
thinking it is a great concern to me
that we treat plutonium with the same
respect and care in all that we treat
highly enriched uranium there is a blue
ribbon panel established by the
President of the United States chaired
by Brent Scowcroft former national
security adviser and Lee Hamilton now
with the Woodrow Wilson
Center and that that pan will make its
report on reprocessing plutonium use by
the United States will make their report
I believe in December or January very
important that that report reflect
concern of a plutonium and I certainly
hope it does so what I'm telling you
hear the bottom line is that if we end
up with plutonium fuels because of this
kind of reason then blutonium will be in
circulation at every reactor so think
about that where our reactors you don't
build reactors in the country you build
them in the cities right that's where
you need the energy so wherever you have
a reactor you will have plutonium in
motion it will be in fuel not a good
thing not a good thing for the United
States but certainly they'll be reactors
all around the world there will be a lot
of plutonium a lots of laconia be
separated and in motion this is a very
bad idea you're trying to control it
there will be arguments that there are
ways of reprocessing so that the
plutonium stream contains some fission
products and byproducts which will make
it very difficult to handle if you're a
terrorist and therefore not useful for a
weapon if you stay interested in this I
invite you to scrutinize those arguments
very carefully I think I should stop
right here it does look like it's seven
o'clock and I thank you for your
attention
alright Bob thank you very much those
who like to post questions i invite you
to step up to the microphone at the
center here i think i might abuse my
position here and ask you the first
question on the way over here you're
talking about how when you became
president the MacArthur Foundation you
found that you could learn about all
kinds of things besides nuclear
proliferation and the question I have is
you know given that the MacArthur
Foundation is working in all different
fields how would you assess the
challenge and the threat of nuclear
proliferation relatively to the other
kinds of threats and challenges that we
face and I and I ask that you know
because we have a lot of students in the
audience here and you know when you talk
to students about things that they care
about they get excited about they get
active about they get excited about
things like climate change like public
health and so on and it's a relatively
self-selected group that gets interested
in the challenge of nuclear
proliferation are these students wrong
do they have the wrong priorities how
would you assess nuclear proliferation
relative to some of the other things
that we should care about every
graduation speaker cannot resist telling
the youth that's before them to follow
your passions and it's unfortunate that
it's a cliche but you know things become
a clich for a reason it's almost
irresistible for certainly for an old
guy to say to you follow your passion I
am the president of the foundation that
has an incredibly broad menu of areas of
work reflecting these broad values of
concern for the human condition so we're
in to domestically to
education K through 12 we're into
community building and reduction of
violence and creation and preservation
of low-income housing or into juvenile
justice reform I could go on and on
about the domestic stuff we're doing
internationally or into human rights
international justice maternal mortality
and other issues of human productivity
and health we are trying to advance
higher education and certain selected
places and we're interested in in
national security broadly defined
including this area I'm have devoted a
fair amount of my career to political
military issues in the national security
united states and international security
and i have never been bored doing that
and i was always confident that the work
would never get done but i always
thought that I could make a contribution
and that it was extremely important I
could imagine now particularly that
since I've moved to the MacArthur
Foundation being able to get comparable
II interested in any of the areas i just
mentioned when I was that you might
wonder what the president of the
MacArthur Foundation does all day
essentially I listened you know and I
get briefed particularly this was I'm
just finishing my first year so I
quality that I have a tight grip on his
ignorance and so I'm listening to all
these experts in the foundation who have
worked these issues all their lives tell
me about the issue and then my job is to
really go out with them the staff to
visit the grantees the people we be not
an operating foundation we give money we
that's what we do we give money away to
the civil society to NGOs and
international organizations that advance
our values and our interest so it might
be a group that's reducing maternal
mortality in Nigeria or India it might
be school system in New York as you know
be
mar i'll be visiting some of the
grantees in the city we were working on
digital media and learning and with one
of your schools in particular so I get
to see the grant deed is working there
and I also get to see the people which
on impact whether it's kids in seventh
grade or whether it's women in Nigeria
or whether it's one of our conservation
projects in Madagascar and I can get
pretty passionate pretty quickly about
saving species in all around the world
we operate on hot spots but I feel
passionately about all those issues this
is the one that I picked but I'm not
here to tell you that it is superior in
any moral or ethical weight is a lot of
other things you can do and as I used to
say as a closer when I was a Dean at
Georgetown and was always looking to
raise money for my school please some of
you go into financial services because I
need gifts that part of my life is
apparently over so I'm not saying that
anymore but one can do good in a lot of
different ways certainly when I look at
the menu and macarthur foundation i'm
struck by the dozens of ways one can
okay thank you Paul when when people
talk about the possibility of a nuclear
intervent I'm sorry a military
intervention against Iran one thing
that's frequently brought up is the idea
of Israel acting alone is that at all
feasible does Israel have military
capacity to conduct a as you describe
the multi-day protracted repeat
operation in the situation where the
United States was actually against it I
think I all I want to say about that is
this that
whatever capability Israel has to launch
a strike against Iran to destroy its
nuclear facilities that ability in that
capacity is less than what the United
States has and to the best of my
knowledge the ability of the United
States to do that is limited I don't
mean that we couldn't really ruin their
day but I don't believe that stopping
the program is a plausible outcome from
even a series of strikes over a series
of days one would have to contemplate
REE striking to a period of time Iran
has been aware that the program might be
subject to attack and has put facilities
underground so the problem facing the
United States is even more acute for
Israel who regards the Iranian program
as as they say an existential threat
okay Nick hi I was wondering first if
you could offer your thoughts on
evaluating the relative risk of nuclear
terrorism today versus in say like 1985
or the fall of the Soviet Union and
second to what you attribute those
differences in the risk level he had
like the changing nature of terrorism or
what yeah I I frankly was not thinking
about me to a terrorism in 1985 but I
would seem to me that given the way I
think about it these days which is in
terms of the availability of fissile
material and of people interested in
that kind of terrorism and these are
these are the two factors i would point
to in response
there are books on my shelf and I
imagine the shelves of others in this
room that talk about terrorism and they
mean something different than the
terrorism we now have they it used to be
said that terrorists want a lot of
attention but not a lot of people dead
that if too many people died since
terrorism is a political act it can be
politically alienating and therefore
counterproductive so the idea of the
terribly lethal virus being spread by
terrorists or a nuclear weapon being
used by terrorists seemed to be
inconsistent with the idea the objective
of any terrorist group was seeking
sympathy for their cause that style
terrorism has been overtaken by another
kind of terrorism in it so with often
with an apocalyptic view of the world Oh
machinery co comes to mind in the
japanese case or al-qaeda and our case
where there are documents that show al
Qaeda having made a calculation about
the numbers of thousands of American
innocents who could be killed quite
legitimate legitimately in light of the
numbers of deaths Muslims caused
directly or indirectly by US policy over
the years so there's a kind of a sort of
a Just Cause argument being made and I
put that in heavy quotes that phrase
just caused by some Muslims I don't I
don't believe this is main line or
Islamic thought and please don't don't
think I'm making that case what I am
saying is that I think most of us who
have looked at this believe that we're
al-qaeda to succeed in manufacturing or
otherwise acquiring a nuclear weapon and
introducing it into an American city it
would not hesitate to detonate it so the
first thing that's different from 19
85 is this kind of terrorism the second
thing is if you have been talking about
Nicotera and not biological terrorism I
will say that in the model that I'm most
concerned about his all material
availability in the construction of an
improvised macule device that there is
more nuclear material around these days
than was around 30 years ago but we're
25 years ago so i think that the threat
is greater now than it was then Harrison
historically what do you think were the
longer term implications for the policy
of denial during the 1970s that's that's
a great question because at the time you
might guess that some were arguing that
denial would be provocative that we
would do better if we would allow access
to this technology under the right
circumstances which meant international
safeguards I don't believe that to be
true myself I'm remembering the how hard
we fought to persuade the French and the
Germans not to build any Italians not to
build or contribute to the construction
of enrichment or reprocessing plants in
the list cases Pakistan and North Korea
South Korea Iran Brazil Argentina I
could go on and I think the policy of
denial behind it an argument that there
was no good economic rationale for
reprocessing or enrichment there is a
they was then and is now a market in
enrichment so if you are a utility in
Sweden and you you're looking to get
some in rich duranium fuel for your
reactor you can go to your n co in
Europe you can go to Euro diff in Europe
you can go to Russia you can go to the
United States maybe soon you can go to
Japan see there's a market and you can
get the best price on uranium and the
best price on enrichment services for
reprocessing the argument goes that
there is no economic argument right now
for reprocessing there might be one
eventually depending on the price of
uranium I what I didn't explain here is
that they're the reason why countries
might want to recover the plutonium is
the plutonium is a fissile material
which means it visions with fast or slow
neutrons like uranium-235 the fissile
isotope of natural uranium and so when
you have plutonium you can replace the
uranium-235 that you would have
increased in content in proportion in in
the uranium for the fuel of a low and
rich director with plutonium and
therefore you would need less uranium
and you wouldn't need as much in a way
of enrichment services so there's fuel
value in the plutonium but it's very
hard to make a economic case then it
makes sense these days until the price
of uranium enrichment services change
that's very contentious and people will
disagree with that proposition okay Gus
given in the past couple years the surge
and concerned about climate change and
especially with the BP oil spill and all
this talk that you know oil is our dicks
oil is not sustainable I was wondering
if you thought that was a real threat
and if so is nuclear energy going to be
part of the solution and if not what are
the other vibe you know yeah yeah I'm
enough of an expert on this stuff to
know i'm not an expert on this stuff so
i'll tell you what i think but you know
it's sort of a word to the wise here i
don't believe that at least now you can
have a serious energy policy that is
sensitive to our concerns about carbon
fuels and climate change that does not
include nuclear energy in the mix you
may be surprised to hear that I'm an
advocate of nuclear energy I am I am a
death on wheels to the use of plutonium
fuels but to nuclear energy the way we
have been using it in this country with
the which is called a once-through cycle
it stops at the pond and then maybe goes
into dry storage in a cement cast that's
what we do and you know sort of my
neighborhood around in Washington that's
what happens to the fuel it goes into
dry storage where it can stay for a
couple hundred years quite happily and
and that seems to meet a way to go
that's a good route to me a good
radioactive waste management solution it
doesn't require us to use yucca mountain
and the president doesn't want to use
Yucca Mountain so this all makes a lot
of sense to me and it can eventually
make sense as part of the mix is it
better to do other things so you don't
have to have the concerns that attached
to the use of nuclear energy that
certain risks that are different yes yes
alternative fuels and principally
efficiency increasing energy efficiency
conservation there's an awful lot of
energy could be saved there and I'm very
enthusiastic that not only that can
happen but it will happen not because we
all turn green because we're wonderful
people but be for economic reasons
and I think we will be using less oil
over time but I think in right now and
we talk about a mix for most countries
nuclear energy should play a part the
French get someplace between eighty and
ninety percent of their electrical
generating capacity from nuclear energy
that's a lot we're around twenty seven
percent which is non-trivial thank you
for a great talk regarding your model
three I don't know how many people here
aware of the fact how much energy and
effort you put into bilateral diplomacy
with North Korea over a number of years
so I kind of want to put you on the spot
and put the spotlight on that part of
your career as you reflect do you
believe the North Koreans were really
wanted to carry out the agreement that
you negotiated the agreed framework
that's first part of the question second
part is to what extent that you fault
the diplomacy of the successor
administration that you didn't serve in
for the fact that we're in this impasse
today and how do you see it playing out
if you looking into the crystal ball how
do you see this crisis resolving itself
hey thank you for that i am of course
completely objective on this subject and
you should trust everything i say we
never knew when we were negotiating with
the North Koreans whether a we would get
a deal and if we did whether they would
stick to it and in retrospect I still
don't know the answer to the second
question obviously we got a deal called
the agreed framework at some point you
deal was concluded in 1994 at some point
between 1996-97 in 1999 it is pretty
clear that the North got into a kind of
arrangement with Pakistan and received
from Pakistan some gas centrifuge
machines
maybe more but that's at least what I
just said is at least that is true so
one is tempted to say well they made the
deal but they did not abide by it it
would be yeah I'm not a lawyer for the
North Koreans lord knows but if I were
gonna say how could this have happened
this might have been North Korean
hedging because they didn't get what
they thought they were going to get and
they might have reasonably expected
which was a political relationship with
the United States you may or may not
remember what happened in the fall of
nineteen ninety-four in addition to the
conclusion of the agreed framework one
of the things that happened is that the
Democrats lost both houses of Congress
and all of a sudden when I went up to
the hill to talk about my negotiations
with North Korea instead of some fairly
friendly in support of democratic chairs
subcommittees they were a whole lot of
people who really didn't like this deal
at all and we're thinking of undoing it
and but we're worried about the
implications of that what I'm saying is
there was no enthusiasm for the
political part of the deal with North
Korea the North Koreans felt that we
welched on that I don't think whatever
welching we may or may not have done was
material as a lawyer might say what they
did in their cheating clearly was would
they have continued to pursue this had
the gore administration proceeded with
the negotiation that was planned at the
end of the Clinton administration who
knows in any case this last part of your
question it was I unhappy with the Bush
administration's treatment of North
Korea in September of 2002 and the
answer is yes I was I really thought
that we could have valued the freeze we
had with the North more than we did
instead of taking a position which
insisted that they own up to the
submission program before we ever talk
to them anymore which made it very
unlikely if not inconceivable that
negotiations would continue and then the
north
after we did that they claimed that we
had broken the deal and they went off on
their own way test to dig your device
has produced more plutonium and it has
not been a very pleasant history ever
since all that being said you might
notice that the president has been the
president now for almost a year and a
half or so and we have not had peace and
light with Pyongyang so these are tough
people to deal with looking ahead I
think as I always used to think there's
a way to get into a negotiation with
them that we could come out ahead and
that negotiators have to think this way
you have to keep your eye on the ball in
the national security but you have to be
pretty optimistic that you could pull
something off so I think there is a deal
still to be made with the North it
wouldn't be easy and they're not
chomping at the bit right now for
whatever reason so I'm not I don't
regard to North Korean case as as
critical as some others that we confront
because they're right now the principal
concern I have is a transfer and and be
the domino effect intrinsically I don't
think the North Koreans are going
anywhere with their nuclear program
thank you thank you very much for your
speech you sometimes we hear the phrase
you know we're fighting the last war and
model 1 2 and 3 so it has some component
of that but the issue you brought up
with the non-state actors that's today's
war are tomorrow's war you raise the
issue of HEU controlling that is one of
the ways to to win that war but I was
wondering if there were other things
that you haven't that you like that you
could address of other ways to control
certain files finances or know if you
get interested in this topic looking
here at students you would go back over
what I said about no defense and no
deterrence and one of the things you'd
get interested in is it possible in fact
to recreate some deterrence or maybe to
use a shelling word Compellent and some
of us have been attracted to the idea
that we might be able to find out if
there was a nickel a detonation who did
it not only who did it but who provided
the fissile material we might want to do
that because if we could do that we
could announce that we could do that and
we could in fact issue a sort of well
let's call it a threat and it would be
one that would have to be very careful
with because this fissile material could
come from places that have nuclear
weapons like Russia or Pakistan places
that we do not believe would on purpose
transfer but places that maybe have not
been as rigorous as we might like in
controlling that material now all this
chain of reasoning depends upon the
proposition that we could in fact say to
the world if you detonate a nuclear
weapon on the territory United States or
one of its allies we will find out who
did it and where the material came from
that is called attribution it's the
ability to attribute and you may or may
not know this but your government is
working pretty hard on the problem of
attribution and I can tell you that if
an icky weapon does go off in
your city or a my city in addition to
the many people that would come to help
us all out there be some group of folks
who would come probably wearing white
suits like in the movies and they would
not be coming here to help y'all they'd
be coming here to collect debris and
they would scoop up that debris and they
take it back to the department of energy
laboratories like Sandhya Los Alamos
Livermore and they would do it isotopic
analysis to try to figure out first it
was the core plutonium or was an honor
mr. rhenium or whatever what was the
design like and a lot of other stuff and
could we actually find out where the
plutonium was produced in which reactor
in what country could we figure out what
the technology was used to enrich
uranium was essential for your choice of
diffusion so there are people who are
working on that capability so that we
could say that in fact we could say now
I can say now to you that it's possible
we could figure this up that's not as
powerful as a statement as we might want
to make over time so one of the avenues
that we're pursuing is the idea of
recapturing a little bit of this
deterrence it's really as i say more
compelling in the case of for to adopt
good policies but in the case of North
Korea and North Korea believed that were
they to transfer anything we would trace
it back to them and treat them as though
they were the attacker we might create a
little deterrence out of this so that's
one possible student
thanks very much I have a question about
the idea well about the horrible
scenario you sketched out for us is the
problem nuclear terrorism or is it
al-qaeda specifically getting nuclear
weapons that is it seems to be there are
a lot of terrorist groups that existed a
lot of them we don't think would have an
interest in acquiring nuclear weapons or
at least if they did in detonating it on
US soil this seems to be specific to
groups with a global reach that don't
have much regard for their own survival
that are it's seeking specific concrete
approximately obtainable political goals
al-qaeda is the it seems to me where
that's what we're talking about so is
this a forecast then that would depend
upon the continued success of al-qaeda
or is this a broader issue than that and
let me just add to that
how much interest has al-qaeda shown in
acquiring a nuclear weapon okay as I say
in California way broader think Oklahoma
City suppose I told you instead of this
fertilizer surveys gas enhanced
explosion that took down to Murtha
building that they had access to a
nuclear device that produced sub kiloton
yield so maybe half a Katie now katie is
a thousand tons of TNT equivalent so
this would be 500 tons of TNT equivalent
which would be order of magnitude or
more bigger and explosion than they God
do you think they wouldn't have done it
I have no reason to think they would oh
no that too many dead people I only want
to kill this many dokie I don't get that
I get apocalyptic the same thing with um
Rico I'm sure Rico I mean how much know
about these folks that was not al-qaeda
but this was they had a scout in uranium
all over the world I mean they were well
financed they attempted the anthrax
thing failed at it they killed people
before they hit the subway with people
at a little party they went to so they
clearly they wanted massive death so I
don't see this as al-qaeda specific it
is just it's irresistible when I'm
talking about this not to think about an
al-qaeda group or branch group because
they have a particular hatred for the
United States and a belief that the
United States has been behind so much
death and destruction and
in the Arab world but by no means is it
limited to al-qaeda in my view second if
you the second party question was but do
we have specific knowledge that al-qaeda
has been after nuclear weapons the
answer is absolutely yes we have a
couple of I don't wanna say funny as an
hilarious but the couple of Pakistani
scientists from the nuclear program
showed up with designs for a nuclear
weapon in al-qaeda it caves in
Afghanistan and we got the designs they
are awful but you know these were people
from the nuclear program not clearly
from the nuclear design program but from
the nuclear program which is quite large
in Pakistan so we know that we also know
that al Qaeda has advertised I mean this
tip advertised for nuclear scientists so
I you know they could be wanting to
build a peaceful nuclear plant but I
doubt it so I don't think there's any
question about al Qaida's interest in
this and but I really do mean this is a
terrorist issue when I talk about 10 or
20 years I'm just trying to get you to
think about not that it it hasn't
happened yet maybe it won't happen but
this does not go away and anything we do
that exacerbates the problem such as
from my perspective used plutonium fuels
increases the likelihood whatever the
chance is that it's going to happen this
year multiplied out over 20 years or
even longer and it becomes a very
troubling phenomenon thank you all very
much thank
so we're taking next week off in our
series but please join us again two
weeks from tonight at the same time same
place for Philip Zelikow thank you
you